LWIA-ah!! LWIA-ah!!
LWIAY, the hot new word that everyone is saying...
But what does it mean? Roll the intro.
Leave your entries in the sub reddit bros
and I'll watch submissions
in the next episode of
LWIAY(Le Why)
What a week it has been. Oh look. What is this?
YouTube removes Logan Paul as preferred ad partner and cancels his YouTube Red projects.
I mean Logan..
Welcome to the fam
Come here
Someone needs a hug. I know how it feels.
Don't worry! Just make sure your videos are ten minutes long,
and you add an extra mid roll-in
you should be fine and you shouldn't notice any difference
Don't worry about it. It's-It's gonna be great for you Logan
I know you were trying to become like a billionaire or something like that
I'm sure dreams come true for those who wait
Now in the meantime, we're gonna review the me-memes that you have posted on the PewDiePie
Submission subreddit. It is the greatest subreddit on all of Reddit, okay?
You don't need to go anywhere else, but to this place. Huh we got memes about my chair.
Huh can it do this?
*burps*
Yes it can!
I mean no it can't because my chair is $399. Check out my chair now
*BURPS*
Now that we have that out of the way, let's review the memes. Oh, will you look- *laughs*
Would you look at that?
Does this chair need its own channel or something with what's happen- What do you wanna tell me?
Spend $399 already -Nice Guy PewDiePie
Come on it's a nice chair man.
I think you like it.
Oh look at that. More chair.
2018.. The year of the *uh* chair.
God dammit!
When people ask how you make millions and billions of dollars
Well, yes.
Seeing how much I made him my last merch sale. I understand why Logan keep pushing for his *uh* merch man
God damn, I could retire guys. There is hope buy my chair so I can retire.
I have spaghet down- *laughs*
No. Eh. No.
E-books are so useful. You can read thousands of books with just one small device.
It's so much better than normal books. Yeah, that's all cool and stuff, but CaN YoU dO tHIs?
No, they can't Kindle can't so far we have three out of four chair memes. Let's move on.
Uh! What is this? A video.
**Bad and Boujee by Migos begins to play**
Skrattar Du™
If young metro don't trust you I'm go gon' shoot you
HEY!!
f***in' on yo b***h she a- KA-KA-KA- cookin' up dope in the- SKIDIKI-PAP-PAP
SKYA- jeff
We are number one! HEY! We are number one!
The real Youtube wind-rewind LEAKED
We got- net neutrality- too
I put a whole in yo' parents-
can't keep my dick in my pants
I trap, trap, trap on the phone
*Crash Bandicoot: WOAH* Movin' that corn flakes
BOOM
*Gucci Gang x8*
Spent ten racks on a new chain
Ma bih love doin cocaine OOh
*Pewds laughs*
Oh yeah-
*swallowing sound*
Omae wa mou shindeiru
NANI?????
GET OUT OF MY CAR NOW
So much $@#%%$#  better
Video: Last midday chime for some time
*Big Ben chimes to Dance Till You're Dead*
*Dance Till You're Dead begins playing*
"Pewds laughs*
*Crash Bandicoot: WOAH x11*
*Lil Uzi Vert: Yuh x15*
*Jake Paul: BRo x18*
All right -NO NO NO Don't pause there! God damn it. I'm gonna leave a link to this one in the description check it out
YouTube, you need to leave these these people in charge for your rewind you didn't even have to shoot anything you don't even need a
Budget, and it's already a hundred times better. My god incredible.
I'm the greatest bird the perfect hunter and the sign of a nation
BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? (laughs)
WHY is that funny, IT'S NOT!
(realizes it's kinda funny, laugh)
Only $399 and that bald eagles nick will just go
(fake neck cracking mouth noise)
Skrrr! Ohhh yeah, Brad told me about this. They basically -(chuckle)
YouTube Re-Red released like another episode of
Their show called "Do you want to see a dead body?" at the same time as everything was happening with Logan Paul.
They try to- they try to hush that down a bit, but no they're like eh.
[ Youtube's stupid laugh ]
Scare Pewdiepie? NO NO NO. You want to see a dead body though? .
[8/10 burp]
Give me money. Please I need order-
I need to order a prostitute friend what that **** man money doesn't hang on trees. (LOL)
Oh shit. Well, not if your Logan Paul, Logan Paul going beyond the deep -
fis- fis- fea- fiso-fes
Philosophical, I just, I already lost the point.
I don't know why I even try to speak anymore-
someone send help.
For $399 you can send me some help  everybody!
*deep inhale*
$399!
Him:Hey wanna, go out on a date with me. [GIRL VOICE]: Sorry. I have a boyfriend.
HIM: I'm a nice guy. [GIRL VOICE]:My boyfriend is a nice guy too.  Him: But CAN HE DO THIS?
[GIRL VOICE]: Meet me at my place in 10 minutes - [LAUGHS]
What do I do if i'm a wahmen? You can still respect wahmen if you're a wahmen. -Don't make me laugh!
*Tommy Wiseau laugh*
Stupid women don't know how to respect women- [laughs]
You need to photoshop PewDiePie's face on him. Yes. I can look at this edit that Brad did or Sive. But can you do this?
[ Distorted Trap Music ]
Somebody touched my spaghett.  Somebody's in dis house..  .
[snickers]
[Clapping]
Good meme.
unexpected, well done.
So we were bored in math class today
and someone
Someone's ringtone went off as the meme
in the new Pewdiepie video sweet smile sadistic suicide and some girl yelled out
"stop being a jerk to Logan" and of course ringtone boy said "can he do this" and he
leaned all the way back and fell-[starts dying laughing]
Did that actually happen hmm, and then the whole class clapped and the teacher gave him $100 because he was a genius
Don't forget that Einstein showed up to congratulate the young genius and the Juag-young genius named Albert
He started with 'very nice' though the teacher gave him £399 so HE CAN DEW DIS!
Good Memessss
Pewdiepie has changed so much over the years. I'm so proud of him
Video: We're going to show you a series of videos with the challenges you can't smile or laugh while watching
Better Felix: Why not?
That's the whole point it's a challenge
Felix after insanity hit: SKRATTAR DU, FÖRLORAR DU!!
So sad
Sometimes sometimes I wake up at night, and I think to myself; Jesus Christ, I've become raywilliamcancer
That girl is so cute. I wonder what she's listening to.
Oh yeah, did you see, [UH]  man man sang it, so good wait someone mashed us together
Let's check it out
CLAP
SPANK
OOF
OUGHHHGHHGHGHHHHHH
His Swedish is so incredible like I-I-I-I-
I didn't know he was a Swedish man.
Please some caption him
Oh
Johnny you're a legend. Thank you very much for making this. The YouTube app seems to be broken for me
Can you check it out? Hi Anirudh, Let us know what it's happening, and we'll do our best
Scare PewDiePie season 2 isn't out yet, and you said it was gonna come out in March
That's right scare PewDiePie season 2 in March
It's gonna happen or else YouTube will face my anger
Do you want me angry YouTube? Oh my god? Is there another bait? Can you guys stop
[UH] with team Youtube-[laughs]
Well done, well done keep baiting YouTube actually, that's funny
@#$% 'EM.
Cutting the video if PewDiePie is answering the door
reaching the ten minute mark- [laughs]
A BRAD meme how about that? Look at that Brad gets to be included. Too bad no one cares about Sive
For only 399 you can become a true Swistain as well. Chair: The vast majority of you cannot afford me.
F: you have a voice now
Chair: Can you shut up about me for once?
Don't listen to the chair! [Chair yelling 'No']Don't listen to the Chair!
Ok Team, I need  another three minutes for the video
What should I do? ~Check your door. ~Advertise your chair ~Watch more memes
Yeah
Maybe if you posed some actually decent memes I could watch more memes
Up vote for pewds to play us a song on his guitar, okay alright
[Trys to Sings] Leave your answers in the comments below
I'll keep my favourites in the next episode of
LWIAY [Ends singing]
It's not tuned and it's missing a string and I can't be bothered right now
Okay, leave your memes in the LWIAY subreddit
You could get immortalized. People who look at this show in the future and say "This is where it all started.
This is where it all went downhill." Do you want to be part of history or not?
I'm giving you this opportunity to post OUR MEMES, my dudes
Check out the link in the description. Submit your meme. I know you're sitting on that
Haha, don't miss out on it, and that's it for me for now.
Leave a like if you enjoy watching
Thank you guys for submitting all the memes
I love it. This has become my favorite show and my my weekly favorite thing literally. I don't even have to prepare anything,
I just.. [You guys do all the work LAUGH]
Skrattar Du. God Dammit..